the health and social care secretary
Matt Hancock so what is it that you are
proposing to do when it comes to
dementia well we're going to double the
funding for dementia research dementia
is it's a terrible condition
partly because more people are surviving
through strokes and through cancer more
people now live with dementia in their
declining years and we want to tackle
that so we're going to double the
funding but more importantly we're going
to bring together what we're calling a
moonshot goal a national mission to to
galvanize the research community to make
sure they're funded to bring the
companies together as well that that do
research into this area and the
charities who do so much to try to find
a cure and there is hope on the horizon
of being able to find a cure probably in
the first instance it'll be something
that slows down the onset of dementia
and then finding a cure when we can I'm
just absolutely thrilled to be Hill to
make this announcement because it really
affects me personally my my grandmother
suffered with dementia in her last 5
years or so of her life she was an
incredibly vibrant sharp woman and then
and then watching that decline was
really heart-rending and I know that
there's so many people who feel the same
and they're affected and and as a
society I think it's something we can
come together and do and it's a really
good example of the positive change that
we want to see I'm sure that many people
of course listening to this with
experience of people loved ones with the
dementia will have sympathy of you and
the situation with your grandmother as
well of course
yeah and we know of course that dementia
is something that is probably going to
be more of a challenge for ours in the
years ahead as a country I mean is this
money really enough or is this just
really just keeping at a standing still
pace oh no this is a this is a doubling
of the the government research budget
but what I also hope can come as part of
it is bringing some of the the big
charities who've done a lot of research
galvanizing their effort bringing
together the scientists from around the
world who are working on this and making
sure they're fully supported and
essentially putting putting at their
disposal all of the power of government
to try to sort this problem so you know
it's it is about the money of course
that's an important part of it but it's
about more than that it's about bringing
people together and say we are going to
crack this we're going to find that cure
and we're going to to back you to make
it happen and put all of the the
resources of the of the NHS and the
funding budgets at the disposal of this
moonshot make it a real national mission
talking about the big healthcare
challenges of the future I really want
to talk to you about social care because
when Boris Johnson first became prime
minister he said I'm announcing now on
the steps of Downing Street that we will
fix the crisis in social quiet once and
for all and with a clear plan we had
prepared to give every older person the
dignity and security they deserve so if
he's going to keep that promise then
what is that clear plan that you are
proposing yes well we're going to set
out in our manifesto tomorrow a
three-point plan on Social Care the
first is that we need to have more
funding in the short term to support
people it's both older people and of
course people of working age who need
support through social care so we have a
5 billion package of extra funding but
everybody knows that this is not a
problem that can be fixed with just more
short-term measures they're important
but they can't fix it so we're also
going to seek a cross-party consensus I
want to build a consensus in the same
way that we have a consensus behind the
NHS in this country I want to have a
consensus behind the solution to social
care and so I look forward to working
with other parties some of the other
parties have also stated that they'll
take the same approach but we're
absolutely determined to fix it now then
we've put also some details on how but
we also want to be open minded to bring
that consensus together but what we're
absolutely clear about is that we want
to end the injustice in which some
people
have to lose their homes to pay for
their care you know there are if you
suffer from cancer for instance then the
state takes care of you but if you
suffer from dementia that we were just
talking about then many people end up
having to lose their homes in order to
pay for their care you can't tell in
advance if you're going to suffer from
dementia if you're going to need care
about 10% of the population need the
care of the cost of more than 100,000
pounds over their lifetime
but about on the other hand about a
quarter of the population don't have any
care needs at all and so we're going to
tackle that injustice by bringing people
together and because it's a long-term
solution that's needed it's really best
done with that cross-party consensus I
just want to I just want to get this
straight Boris Johnson's promised a
clear plan on Social Care we know
there's a crisis in Social Care the
association of directors of adult social
service for example say tens of
thousands of older and disabled people
and not getting out to do really really
simple things like washing like dressing
that they're cut off in a sea of inertia
because of cuts and listening to what
you're saying
you're basically just saying you want to
get around a table and find a consensus
to do something I mean how long did it
take you to come up with that that's not
a plan is it the plan is very clear
because we're putting money in as well
we're putting money in in the short term
and over the last couple of years
there's been a rise of over ten percent
in the money going into Social Care and
we're going to do more with this five
million pounds that we're putting 5
billion pounds that we're putting
forward but we also do need to make sure
we get as much of a cross-party
consensus as possible ok and the way to
do that is to set out the principles
which talk about that money that you're
talking about that show with 5 billion
pounds so 1 billion pounds a year next 5
years if you win the election but 7
point 7 billion has been cut from the
social debt care budget since 2010 so if
that doesn't even cover what then can't
does it that's that's not quite right
the social care budget has been rising
since 2015 we put an extra I'm talking
about since 2010 when the Conservatives
came into coalition when it came into
power well we all know that savings had
to be made because
the Labour Party left no money do you
remember the note that was left in the
Treasury I'm sorry there is no money
left it looks like from the Labour
manifesto they're proposing to do even
worse if they were to get into power at
this election so of course savings had
to be made but we've I'm glad that we've
now been able to to increase the amount
of money that's going towards Social
Care including a billion pounds two
months ago which means that we can we
with this commitment we're making we can
stabilize the current system and we're
putting our money where our mouth is so
to speak but but we've also got to have
that long-term solution and we're laying
out our principles we and the way that
we want to tackle it but I look forward
to talking to people in other parties to
actually make it to make it happen and
to get a plan that will stick there's a
bit like pensions when you make a big
pensions reform you want that to be
cross-party
because the decisions you make now
affect people in many many years to come
it's a truth that you've been a bit
burned by what happened at the last
election when Teresa may set out her
plans to try and reform change of social
care system and then there was a
backlash it was controversial so now
you're basically letting politics Trump
policy making no I think good
policymaking involves bringing that
consensus together and that is that is
best done outside of an election
campaign but I would also say this that
you know I am against the idea that
people lose their homes to pay for care
you know it really matters to me it
matters - it matters to so many people
you know people being able to buy their
own home and it's something that often
they work their whole life for and the
idea that you then have your home taken
away from you because of the because you
suffered from dementia when somebody
else who suffered from a different
condition didn't lose their home I think
that is a that is a bad place for
society to get to and I want to fix it
and so the proposal that was put forward
in the manifesto in 2017 and of course
we politico's can debate the impact it
had on the election and I've certainly
got my views
but I also think it was the wrong policy
I don't want people more people losing
their homes to pay for care I want
people to have the security to know that
if they put money aside every month into
a mortgage and work all their life for
it they're going to be able to keep that
home it's a deep deep human instinct
that I feel very strongly and I
understand and millions and millions of
people feel this way and that injustice
should be tackled rather than made worse
so that's why we've made that principle
clear and then I look forward to
engaging with the other parties on how
we put it into practice and quick
thought from you on another healthcare
story in the news today GPS voting to
scrap home visits from part of their key
contracts is this something that your
contour where does health secretary know
it won't happen of course
GPS sometimes need to to home visits and
we're going to fund and train and hire
more GPS 6,000 more of them over the
next Parliament but this idea that's
been put forward by the GPS won't fly
okay
now talking about Brett said and one of
your colleagues I wish he seemed like
the chief secretary to the Treasury and
told the Telegraph that no dual planning
would resume if the Conservatives win
the next election is that right would No
Deal be back on the table if you win a
majority no we've got a great deal and
we're going to deliver on that deal and
in fact the big thing that's happened in
the last 24 hours on brexit is that
whereas Boris is absolutely clear that
we're going to deliver brexit on his
deal I'm absolutely thrilled that he got
the good deal and lots of people said
that he couldn't and he delivered it and
I backed him to get a deal and he got it
and the reason we're having the election
is because Parliament then wouldn't
allow him to put that deal through and
what we've seen on the other side and
found out last night I think a really
big moment in this election Jeremy
Corbyn saying that he has actively
decided to be indecisive on the biggest
issue of the day it won't wash with
voters I think it's an absolute disaster
you can't ask this country to be its
prime minister whilst not having a view
on the biggest issue of the day which is
brexit and I thought
the conservative policy just to be
crystal if I could just finish this
point if I can just finish this point
after this election only one of two
people could be Prime Minister either
Boris Johnson or Jeremy Corbyn and we
now know that only one of those two
Boris has got a plan to deliver brexit
and get this the politics of this
country moving forwards after the the
last three years because I'm still a
little bit confused that the chief
section is Treasury say that no dual
planning would resume if their concept
is win the election we know that there
is a tight timeframe as well to get this
trade deal stitched up if you say that
you don't want to extend the transition
beyond the end at the end of 2020 so No
Deal brexit absolutely off the table as
as the Prime Minister is Dominic robbed
of said No Deal is not going to happen
because we've got a great deal and we're
gonna put that deal through every
Conservative candidate is signed up to
it I just hope beyond hope that we can
get a majority so that finally we can
get the country moving you know it
doesn't matter how you voted in the
referendum three and a half years ago
you as as you know I voted remain but
I'm a Democrat and we respect the
results of Democratic votes in this
country because we are a democracy the
world's you know most famous democracy
and that means you've got to respect the
result and whether you like it or not
and so everybody who's standing to be a
Conservative MP at this election is
signed up to and determined to deliver
brexit on Boris's New Deal and then we
can get onto all the other things like
Social Care that we were talking about
that have been stuck because of the
brexit debate about any other party a
vote for any other party will lead to
more of the chaos and dither and delay
that we've seen over the last three
years there's an only one way to get the
country moving forward and that's to
vote conservative now well I've got you
I just want to finish and with some of
these campaign videos that you've been
posting on social media because you is
they of course a little bit of a stir
some of them shall we these kind of like
little selfie videos that you've been
doing
around the country on the campaign trail
saying things like its Yorkshire it's
before 7:00 in the morning it's raining
and we are ready to go in one recent one
as well you appear to have a tree
growing out of your head in that video a
little bit Alan Partridge oh I mean oh I
love campaigning and I love general
election campaigns and I've been working
incredibly hard
this one I've now done 71 constituency
visits right across the country many
many more to come there's so much
investment going into our health service
that there's so many places I need to go
to explain the extra scanners we're
putting in the extra hospitals that
we're building the the the upgrades that
we're doing so I'm fly over I'm not
flying I'm going around the country and
and I think social media is one tool to
explain that and yeah it's funny when I
go and knock on doors and the people say
to me essentially two things one invest
in the NHS which we're doing and to get
brexit done and that is the message of
this election there's only one party
that can get breaks it done in order to
invest in the NHS in fact I was on a
door in Chatham yesterday day before
yesterday and this the gentleman opened
the door was with Tracy Crouch brilliant
brilliant candidate brilliant has been a
brilliant MP and he said I I work for
you pointing at me and I'm voting for
you Tracy
because you're you're investing in the
NHS and you're gonna deliver brexit and
I thought well you know that sums this
election up okay thank you very much
might need to work on the framing a
little bit in those future videos but
thank you very much Matt Hancock that